okay before I move to the whole solution
have a look at this with me can you
describe what is it that I'm doing from
the question to my first line of work
you can you believe tell me articulate
what is that about
okay so I'm breaking apart this thing
see this thing if I expended it it would
have 12 terms right but all 12 terms are
going to look almost identical except
for those powers the powers on the top
these guys and also that binomial
coefficient out there it's going to be
11 C 0 11 C 1 etc okay so being that
they're all identical that's why the
general term is used to what I've got
here this thing here is the general term
right and all I'm saying on the left
hand side is Sigma notation all that
saying is hey add up all 12 of them for
the different values of up how about
from 1 1 - why - what's going on what am
I done
that's the difference yeah you take your
necks yeah fantastic so you can see the
question is all about the X to the 9
turn right so therefore I want to get
those X to the nines out of there
these are not the expedite it's just the
X's full stop here are some of the X's
and he is the rest of the x's okay just
watch out with your index notation do
you see what's happening with my now is
there X to the negative 1 becomes x how
many minds are so I've got new powers do
you agree with this do you agree that
hell yeah
so once you might end up like that yes
my shutting
so you can see now this is me finishing
off thank you sir
I'm tightening everything up until I get
the X term with whatever power it's got
I want that power to be nine yes so I
said what will be excellent my turn
there's the power of there that needs to
be done so I say for our by this eleven
equal to nine go ahead and solve do you
agree with my arithmetic at all check
out and then what I've said is well I
only want the coefficient I don't
actually want the answer tonight
so therefore these bits here numerically
our you're left with when R is equal
five what am i ashamed of you okay now
can I point out a couple of things
really quickly one thing that I want you
don't look for in the solution that
you're marking is all of the extra stuff
that tells you what's going on let me
show you what the comments solution to
this that I've seen many hundreds of
times that I've marked which has all the
right mechanics but I doubt would get
for months this is what I often see
here we go
so maybe the answer you're looking at
looks a lot like this and you can sort
of see what they're doing right you have
to do a bit of guesswork you have to do
a bit of my greedy you have to say oh
what are they doing that looks like the
general term and then they say oh I've
got before I - Levin I guess I want that
to be nine and so on okay but this is a
really poor solution because even though
all the numbers are right that all the
algebra is accurate I have no idea what
you're doing right you pulled out the
general term you haven't said that
you're doing that so really you're
missing a lot of information when you
don't say this is the sum of la ba ba ba
ba ba ba right and then when you work at
these things tell me what's going on
tell me
that's what demonstrates understand so
all those bits really really matter you
might even frustrating because they take
you time to buy but accurate clear
unambiguous communication takes time so
to do a problem I'll come back to this
if you haven't got it yet but let's move
on everything
okay now you can see what I've got here
I there are three pieces to every one of
my solutions and I want to point out all
three because you'll notice them again
and again and again the first thing is
over here in the top right-hand corner
see this I always have a picture in my
mind now a picture like ID a bag here a
picture may be easy or it may be hard to
get into your head it will not become
easier if you do not practice the skill
so my suggestion is you can see this
picture is not beautiful it doesn't even
have any numbers on it all I need is the
general shape once I know what's going
on when is this thing equal to nine okay
this is one of those bouncy things I
know what that looks like and it's gonna
hit nine exactly twice those are the
black points of intersection do you see
that
can you see following on what this means
in relation to my graph what does this
tell you what is this going to find out
from the graph can anyone tell me this
is gonna find one of the points of
intersection which one will it tell me 3
minus 2x which what is that it's the one
on the left isn't it 3 minus 2x is
dropping down so it's gonna tell me this
value over here
do you agree once I get that which
happens to be negative 3 okay when you
solve that other one I met 2x minus 3 do
you see it's the other brush it's the
right hint brunch so it's going to tell
me this value which is 6 ok now my scale
sucks but it doesn't matter I'm just
trying to work out where everything is
oriented in relation to itself so the
first pink piece of the picture was
there
the second part of my algebra the Fed
pot is that the question says graph on a
number line so here is my graph
can I please point out that my graph
does not look like this those points
negative 3 & 6 they are on the number
line right because it matters this learn
up and down so please indicate your
point on the line itself and then you
keep on going those same three pieces
they're going to come up forget it again
here we go have a look at this one we
did this this is an actual question from
your homework a few weeks back that's
what absolute value of x plus X times G
notice exercises zero do you see why
there are the solutions you tell me why
the X's cancel out when X is less than
zero this is going to be negative x
negative x plus x is zero zero never
equals four never ever ever so there are
no solutions what that corresponds to is
over here this graph is never going to
hit four fours up here this guy just
stays down here you never touches it so
I can ignore this part this part does
give me a solution
I mean I'm solving for this let's put
four there okay so what you're finding
is that point of intersection and x
equals two and just like before I
graphed it onto a number
Russia
I'll talk about that in about three
minutes for the finish okay let's finish
out your society get sick of it right
same three pieces pic shop algebra
number one okay this is very similar to
the previous one in fact if you look
closely I just cheated them use the same
graph but I'm asking a different
question of it it says when is this
bouncy graph thing over here greater
than above nine so here's my line that
corresponds to nine and here are the
pods that are above right bring the
highlighter into the exam and do this so
that you can clearly communicate I know
what I'm talking about
these are the parts of the graph that
are relevant and so therefore when I
find my boundaries which by the way I
say I'm finding my boundaries right
that's why these become equal signs
because I know what I'm doing so I
communicate what I'm doing not just
bring out equations out of nowhere when
I find those boundaries I know which
sides of those boundaries I need to be
on do you see why I need to be on the
left of this one and why I need to be on
the right of that one that gets me
outside to these bits that are above
like I want there's my number line why
these hollow I'm not including the
boundaries because the original question
doesn't include boundaries and then last
one so I will leave that there I think
I've explained it and often